[Music]
recent advancements in technology have
allowed animators to push the limits of
their work resulting in more creative
and detailed films and TV shows than
ever before to find out how six of these
stunning and unique animations were
created let's take a look behind the
scenes stop-motion animated movies have
been around for over 100 years
but the production house like estudios
brought this animation style into the
21st century by utilizing 3d printing a
technique that is especially prevalent
in their 2016 masterpiece Kubo and the
two strings
traditionally stop-motion animated
characters had to be made of a moldable
material such as clay so that the faces
of the characters could be changed
however by using 3d printed faces Leica
Studios is able to alter the facial
expressions of its characters more
quickly and consistently
each expression is created using 3d
modeling software the models are then
printed with the 3d printer and magnets
are added to the back of the face so
they can later be attached to the
puppets there were approximately 48
million different combinations of facial
expressions created for the film's main
character kuba his face consists of a
top and bottom faceplate that combine
the tiny scene between the two pieces
was painted out in post-production
because there were so many faces each
face had a code on the back of it in
order to keep all of them organized
advanced 3d printing technology also
allowed Kubo in the two strings to be
able to create intricate puppets that
would be impossible to create otherwise
such as the character called moon beast
who was like his first completely 3d
printed character moon beast was made of
881 individual 3d printed parts 130
color parts and 751 components for the
armatures used in its body and legs
[Music]
Loving Vincent is the first
feature-length animated film in which
every frame was hand-painted using oil
on canvas approximately 65,000 frames in
total the film was painted in the style
of Vincent van Gogh featuring 94 of the
artists original paintings as the
settings for the story in order to
create the film the production team
invented a special animation process
first they filmed actors on a blue stage
with background elements digitally added
later then one of the 125 highly skilled
artists on the team painted over each
frame of this live-action footage in the
style of Van Gogh the paintings were
then photographed in a symbol to
complete the animation process the
producers faced several challenges in
this ambitious project first they had to
change the color palette of several of
Van Gogh's paintings because while van
Gogh painted across all four seasons
the film's plot takes place only in the
summer
additionally van Gogh experimented with
several different styles throughout his
life
so characters had to be painted
differently based on which van Gogh
painting was being used as the backdrop
when the production team realized they
needed to hire more painters to finish
the project on time they discovered that
they're literally weren't enough trained
painters available in Poland where the
film was being made so they posted a job
listing and ended up hiring 45 oil
painters from around the world sifting
through 5,000 applications given all of
these factors it's no surprise that it
took the team about five years to
complete the project the film's director
said that they had without a doubt
invented the slowest form of filmmaking
ever devised
it took producers over a year to create
just 10 seconds of test animation
footage that they were happy with for
spider-man into the spider-verse the
eye-grabbing animation style of the 2018
film looks wildly different from typical
animated movies and it borrows many of
its innovative animation
techniques from comic books one of the
most noticeable differences involves
framerate animated films are typically
24 frames per second and creating a
different image for each frame is known
as animating on once spider-verse broke
the mold and animated much of the movie
on tubes meaning that they kept some
images on screen for two frames each
character's pose lasts longer and is
much more pronounced they alternated
between on twos and on ones depending on
the nature of the scene another defining
characteristic of the film is that there
isn't any motion blur a CGI trick that
most new films use to soften a movement
and make it seem more real instead they
used an old-school technique called a
smear this was used a lot in early
cartoons to create the sense of motion
if you look at a single frame you'll
notice things like multiple limbs to
create the illusion of movement the
producers also decided not to create a
traditional depth of field by using lens
blurs and instead utilized mists
printing inspired by the common error in
comic books when ink is misaligned
when something is in focus the colors
aligned in our crisper while the colors
of background objects are often offset
[Music]
the characters in Netflix's
oscar-nominated film Klaus look
three-dimensional but unlike most
animated movies these days the
characters in Klaus aren't all CGI and
can't even be considered 3d the
characters were first hand drawn inked
and painted using digital tablets then
the artists were able to paint with
light
thanks to software created specifically
for Klaus the second major feature that
helped bring the characters to life and
added to the 3d illusion was texturing
with another piece of software they used
contour lighting and motion to add
surface qualities to specific parts of a
character for example the skin could
appear smooth while the clothing would
be rougher in the end the characters
appeared much more 3d and immersed in
their and VY
as opposed to looking like stickers on
top of an elaborately painted background
while the majority of the film followed
this 2d process the animators did use 3d
models for some characters and objects
and combine the two styles seamlessly
even though these were created using CGI
they were lit the same way as the 2d
characters work
scenes like this chase scene at the end
of the film so seamlessly combined 2d
and 3d elements that it can be difficult
to tell which is which
while audiences and critics were divided
on Disney's 2019 Lion King remake it's
undeniable that the animation was a
technical triumph as it's the most
photorealistic animated major motion
picture to date one of the first steps
in most animation films is
pre-visualization where an extremely low
resolution version of the animation is
created in order to perfect character
movements and camera angles
however The Lion King took a new
approach to this phase creating
simplified animated sequences that could
be viewed in virtual reality the
director and production team would then
put on VR headsets which allow them to
actually step foot in the virtual set
that they had created this allowed them
more freedom to explore each scene and
let them easily set up shots adjust
lighting and choreograph movements this
digital environment helped them emulate
the nature documentary aesthetic that
they were aiming for the Lion King
animation team also ran into the unique
challenge of having to make the animals
not only realistic but also able to sing
and talk in order to pull this off they
time the characters breathing to their
dialogue and would make the belly
muscles and diaphragm tighten that way
it felt like the animals were forcing
air out of their mouths as they spoke
each layer of these animals also went
through a simulation pass an additional
phase of animation where skin details
such as muscle ripples skin wrinkles and
fur interaction are all added striking
that balance between staying true to the
original film
and creating a hyper-realistic Lee
animated Lion King for a new audience
was a particularly tough challenge and
it required 77 million hours of
animation rendering the 2019 Amazon
Prime series undone was created using
rotoscoping the process of drawing
animations over live-action video
footage rotoscoping has been around
since the early 1900s but the
rotoscoping process for undone is so
much more advanced that it's practically
unrecognizable from its predecessors the
producers for undone were originally
going to film the series using
live-action but they ultimately decided
that using rotoscope animation would
give the series the surreal feeling that
it necessitated as the story revolves RN
a young woman who has an unsteady grip
on reality the scenes were initially
shot with actors and minimal sets using
grids on set as reference points for the
animators there was no need for
green-screen because every area of the
frames would be painted over during the
rotoscoping process the live-action was
then rotoscoped
with animators drawing crisp lines over
the footage the rotoscope animation was
then sent to Amsterdam where artists
would use oil-based paints to add colors
and shadows to the footage while many of
the backgrounds were painted in
Amsterdam using oil on canvas some
scenes required backgrounds that were
created using 3d modeling software to
maintain the uniform painted look the 3d
animation team would send a layout to
the painters who would paint over the
image after the painting was complete
the 3d artists could then use the
finished painting as a reference for
texturing the 3d environment
what film do you think we should have
included on the list
what animated film would you like us to
discuss next let us know in the comments
[Music]